because that led us to think that we needed to talk to the human being
and not to the soldier.
We needed to step away from talking
from government to army, from army to army,
and we needed to talk about the universal values,
and we needed to talk about humanity.
And that was when the Christmas tree happened.
This picture that I have here,
you see this is the planning of the Christmas trees,
and that man you see there with the three stars,
he's Captain Juan Manuel Valdez.
Captain Valdez was the first high-ranking official
to give us the helicopters and the support we needed
to put these Christmas trees up,
and he said in that meeting something that I will never forget.
He said, "I want to do this because being generous makes me stronger,
makes my men feel stronger."
And I get very emotional when I remember him
because he was killed later in combat and we really miss him,
but I wanted you all to see him, because he was really, really important.
He gave us all the support to put up the first Christmas trees.
What happened later is that the guerrillas who came out
during the Christmas tree operation and all of that
said, "That's really good, Christmas trees are really cool,
but you know what? We really don't walk anymore.
We use rivers."
So rivers are the highways of the jungle,
and this is something we learned,
and most of the recruiting was being done in and around the river villages.
So we went to these river villages,
and we asked the people,
and probably some of them were direct acquaintances of the guerrillas.
We asked them, "Can you send guerrillas a message?"
We collected over 6,000 messages.
Some of them were notes saying, get out.
Some of them were toys. Some of them were candy.
Even people took off their jewelry, their little crosses and religious things,
and put them in these floating balls that we sent down the rivers
so that they could be picked up at night.
And we sent thousands of these down the rivers,
and then picked them up later if they weren't.
But lots of them were picked up.
This generated, on average, a demobilization every six hours,
so this was incredible and it was about: Come home at Christmas.
Then came the peace process,
and when the peace process started,
the whole mindset of the guerrilla changed.
And it changed because
it makes you think, "Well, if there's a peace process,
this is probably going to be over.
At some point I'm going to get out."
And their fears completely changed,
and their fears were not about, "Am I going to get killed?"
Their fears were, "Am I going to be rejected?
When I get out of this, am I going to be rejected?"
So the past Christmas, what we did was we asked --
we found 27 mothers of guerrillas,
and we asked them to give us pictures of their children,
when they only could recognize themselves, so as not to put their lives in danger,
and we asked them to give the most motherly message you can get,
which is, "Before you were a guerrilla, you were my child,
so come home, I'm waiting for you."
You can see the pictures here. I'll show you a couple.
(Applause)
Thank you.
And these pictures were placed in many different places,
and a lot of them came back,
and it was really, really beautiful.
And then we decided to work with society.
So we did mothers around Christmastime.
Now let's talk about the rest of the people.
And you may be aware of this or not, but there was a World Cup this year,
and Colombia played really well, and it was a unifying moment for Colombia.
And what we did was tell the guerrillas,
"Come, get out of the jungle. We're saving a place for you."
So this was television, this was all different types of media saying,
"We are saving a place for you."
The soldier here in the commercial says,
"I'm saving a place for you right here in this helicopter
so that you can get out of this jungle and go enjoy the World Cup."
Ex-football players, radio announcers,
everybody was saving a place for the guerrilla.
So since we started this work a little over eight years ago,
17,000 guerrillas have demobilized.
I do not -- (Applause)
Thank you.
I don't want to say in any way that it only has to do with what we do,
but what I do know is that our work and the work that we do
may have helped a lot of them start thinking about demobilization,
and it may have helped a lot of them take the final decision.
If that is true, advertising is still one of the most powerful tools of change
that we have available.
And I speak not only my behalf,
but on behalf of all the colleagues I see here
who work in advertising,
and of all the team that has worked with me to do this,
that if you want to change the world,
or if you want to achieve peace, please call us.
We'd love to help.
Thank you.
(Applause)